in 1905 there were almost 20 deaths in
high school and college football because
of this there was a huge public pressure
on whether or not the game would even
still exist from that crisis came the
forward pass came helmets came all these
changes to the game and I see that story
as a great way of looking at what we
have right now how big of an epidemic is
concussion in football right now it's
it's huge 96% of the brains exam from
the NFL 79 percent overall football
players that have CTE San Francisco
49ers linebacker Chris Borland is
retiring at age 24 because he's
concerned about the long-term effects of
the head trauma that football can cause
this was a little shocking to me that
that accident remember $5 play you
soccer this huge huge decision has just
been made on that NFL concussion lawsuit
everyone knew there was going to come a
day of reckoning we haven't really known
until recently how serious concussions
might be we went to a place called the
Burke Institute to talk to researchers
there about how they're using virtual
reality technology to track changes in
their brain caused by all of those hips
the current state of the NFL is that we
are only treating the big hits but
things that cause a concussion matter
what's the scary truth is that every
player that steps on the field for an
NFL game they're sustaining many many
little hits these players are taking 90
hits per game so this is amounting to in
a season more than a thousand hits every
year and that's really worrying us
because then they're not showing acute
signs of concussion so they go under the
doctors Raider
to optimize player welfare what we
really need to do is start to understand
how all of these little hits might be
adding up to a chronic long-term brain
injury or or syndrome
what we're really trying to do with
these tests is hack the brain the first
way that we do that is with smooth eye
tracking what's going to happen is this
system is going to track my eye
movements and so long as I am following
the scene in the way that we want the
person to follow the scene which is a
smooth pursuit movement I'll hear music
to sort of give me the indication that
I'm doing the right thing
so what we're looking at here is the
output of the oculus rift when we go and
take a look at post concussive blow what
we can see is a lot of sort of variance
in the data set that we're collecting
indicating that he took this hit and he
immediately was very very unsteady and
the oculus rift was capable of detecting
that unsteadiness and and showing us how
different he was from baseline in the
future what we're absolutely going for
is before every game after every game do
this five-minute thing it uploads your
data to the cloud and we know how you're
doing that's the way that we're going to
influence the field and that's the way
that we're going to be able to make
data-driven decisions about returning to
play or not returning to play is by
understanding each player inside and out
but what about preventative tracking how
can we monitor hits before they actually
produce that brain injury we checked in
with a company called eye one biometrics
that's making a mouth guard which has
accelerometers within it and using that
they can track exactly what hits people
undergo think of it like a smartphone in
your mouth it's got all of the same
technology microprocessors
accelerometers gyroscopes batteries
antennas etc any time they take a hit
above magnitude it alerts the sideline
staff in real time so the athletic
trainers and medical staff know that
player just took a hit shows them where
it happened how hard that it was
so this is the impact lab we use to
basically verify that our sensor works
head form has a mouth guard in it and
when we hit this they'll get the mouth
care will register an impact the reason
that the the mouth is such a great place
to measure head trauma is it's actually
inside the players head so everywhere
that your upper jaw goes your skull goes
it's firmly affixed to that players head
so unlike putting a sensor in a helmet
helmet moves independently of the
players head so all those things
introduce variables all those things
introduce less accuracy
the reason the tracking impacts is so
important is we're able to understand
the full history of that player so what
is their exposure ban for the lifetime
of their athletic career from that we
now know you know is this player at
greater risk than his or her peers what
does that look like how do we treat this
athlete appropriately so that they're
cared for correctly we'll have players
where you'll see impacts across the
forehead which is actually good because
they're playing
heads-up football you'll see other guys
that have a lot of their hits on the top
of the head you know that helps helps
coaches and trainers identify players
that might need some work on their
techniques
everybody's been focused on making
equipment stronger nobody's made
anything smarter but eventually I would
expect that you're going to see many
elements of a player's gear become not
just stronger gear but smarter gear
so entering the age of smart football
equipment and anyone from research is a
Ivy League universities to designers in
Silicon Valley are interested in trying
to find a way to solve the sort of
problem but concussion of focus we focus
on helmet design because we're in a
collaboration with Lawrence Livermore
National Labs and our effort is to look
at the microstructure of material
because that microstructure is
effectively going to allow us to double
or triple the cushioning effect of a
helmet
in some sense you could have a smart
helmet in the future something that can
sense an impact and relocate that load
depending upon the nature of the impact
whether it's a direct impact or a
glancing impact listen it is an example
of a micro lattice this is made through
3d printing it's a metal though it's
lighter than air it's absorbs energy and
returns to its original form
what we're looking at our materials 5 10
25 years out and those materials will be
able to sense respond and adapt during
play they may not look from the outside
all that different than today's helmets
but the inside and the microstructure
will be completely different
but what if new materials and smart
technology on its own is not going to
solve this problem perhaps we're going
to need to make radical changes to the
game we checked in with a study at the
University of New Hampshire those
looking at what happens when you take
the helmets away from the planes the Hut
program is is prescribed throughout the
course of the season where players will
participate in tackling and blocking
drills without helmets and shoulder pads
in place it just teaches your kids that
you know the head is in the helmet
aren't weapons our tackling is improved
our technique on how attackers include
and our you know blows to the head of
lesson while we're doing this really
caught the kids attention that was the
thing after we started doing it caught
the kids attention that they're doing
this for a reason and the reason is a
pretty good one
I think what we're doing as a culture in
football right now is good
everybody's identifying an aesthetic
consequences I think 50 years from now
concussions will still be an issue but I
don't think they'll be as large of an
issue we're at a critical point right
now where the game has not become
significantly safer but our
understanding of injury has increased
exponentially that's leading to
innovation and so I think you'll see
less issues in the future but you can't
take the violence out of the game when a
big hit happens to a key player at Super
Bowl 100 the coaches on the sidelines
will know immediately exactly what's
going on in that players brain they're
going to be able to decide whether or
not that plan needs to be taken out and
if that player does need to be taken out
perhaps they go to the sidelines they
take a medication and maybe they're back
for the second half
just because we have all this technology
doesn't mean that in 50 years time
football won't still be football instead
it means that we can use that technology
to make the game safer
you